bonjour François Patriat merci d'être
notre invité politique ce matin sénateur
de la Côte d'Or président du groupe RDPI
Renaissance et le groupe qui rassemble
les sénateurs de la majorité
présidentielle on est ensemble pendant
20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Fabrice vessère redond
du groupe Ebra bonjour Fabrice bonjour
Oriane bonjour François patriarche
bonjour les journaux régionaux de l'Est
de la France dont les vôtres évidemment
en Bourgogne Franche-Comté
on a beaucoup d'actualités avec vous on
commence par la Coupe du monde puisque
Emmanuel Macron sera sur place au Qatar
mercredi pour soutenir l'équipe de
France lors de sa demi-finale contre le
Maroc il va faire un aller-retour ou en
cas de qualification il doit rester
jusqu'à la finale
en fin de semaine et qu'il reviendrait
s'il y allait donc
comme il avait fait pour moi ce que vous
vous souvenez-vous
sur l'écologie l'empreinte carbone faire
deux allers-retours en 48 heures
c'est fausse querelles c'est inutile on
voit bien que je crois que les français
si la France va en finale quoi que les
Français apprécieront que le président
majoritairement les 17 millions
personnes qui ont regardé le match
samedi soir à pression il peut y aller
uniquement en tant que supporter des
bleus ou est-ce qu'il doit y aller aussi
en tant que chef de l'État qui doit
exprimer des opinions politiques et qui
doit délivrer un message politique au
Qatar
les événements sportifs même si des
facto même si des facto tout événement
quel qu'il soit en France et politique
malgré tout mais je crois qu'il y va
parce que d'abord il est sportifs très
sportif il aime le foot il connaît le
foot en 3e lieu
je comprendrais mal qu'un président de
la République ne soutiennent pas son
équipe Jacques Chirac à l'époque
souvenez-vous les soutenu avec beaucoup
de véhément c'est même on avait tiré
lui-même à l'époque beaucoup de fruits
en 2018 on voit bien que le président
s'y était engagé il a dit il a vu les
joueurs avant il aura mis le challenge
il a contact avec eux très particulier
il les connaît bien il apprécie donc je
le vois bien François
patriotat il est il était il y a 10 ans
il est pas aujourd'hui pour moi c'est
fini et d'ailleurs cette Coupe du Monde
est une réussite malgré tout est une
réussite je pense qu'elle est une
réussite qui a beaucoup de ferveur dans
moins de regarder tous les gens qui
participent aujourd'hui ce débat on ne
remet pas sur la table au moment où
l'événement démarre et il y a 10 ans on
avait choisi de faire le Qatar on
pouvait le contester à l'époque vous
pouvez
même temps si vous voulez maintenant il
est là allons-y donc notre équipe et
faisons ensemble qu'on se retrouve
dimanche prochain et on soutient notre
équipe mais il doit y avoir aucun
message politique parce que vous
rappelez qu'Emmanuel Macron a dit faut
pas politiser le sport quand Amélie ou
de la castéral a mis des sports
avec des manches arc-en-ciel c'est une
manière de politique
je trouve que si à la fois courageuse et
que c'est bien et que je la soutiens et
si le président fait passer les messages
il a déjà dit par ailleurs il a dit rien
mais il a dit que le Qatar avait évolué
qui a encore du chemin à faire mais
c'est pas en fermant la porte ou en
rompant aujourd'hui je pense qu'on a des
relations internationales légales avec
le Qatar il y a pas de
sur la réforme des retraites c'est un
gros dossier qui attend le gouvernement
alors d'abord avant de parler du fond
sur le calendrier est-ce que vous nous
confirmez que Elisabeth borne présentera
cette réforme jeudi
la semaine prochaine mercredi voilà
mercredi après-midi elle annoncera le
texte de loi enfin le texte doit le
projet de loi la lancera surtout
laboutissement des concertations menée
par Olivier du socle et qui ont été
nombreuses et fructueuses et après quand
ce texte arrivera au Parlement qu'on
sera-t-il présenté au Conseil des
ministres est-ce qu'il viendra d'abord
au Sénat ou d'abord à l'Assemblée alors
comme c'est un texte qui sera sans doute
un PLF il peut pas venir au Sénat en
premier
vous nous confirmez que ça passera par
ce véhicule je pense ce sera ce véhicule
là donc ça veut dire que ça commencera à
l'Assemblée moi j'aurais bien aimé que
ça commence que non mais cette forme là
empêche cette forme bien ensuite je
pense un conseil des ministres qui
interviendrait à la mise en vie
mi-janvier et puis je vois bien le texte
de loi arrivé qu'un jour après parce
qu'il faudra passer le Conseil d'État
etc donc début février
[Musique]
comme c'est un projet de loi de finance
ça va plus vite que les navettes
classiques sur les textes allez on va
dire fin février au Sénat et puis ça
devrait être se conclure 8 mars donc le
choix est fait ça sera un budget
rectificatif pourquoi ce choix c'est
c'est vous avez peur de du vote du
Parlement
aujourd'hui de l'attitude de
l'opposition des oppositions y compris à
l'Assemblée nationale on pourra
peut-être des républicains mais ils sont
divisés sur le sujet si on veut que de
ce texte passe d'abord on va tout faire
le gouvernement va tout faire pour
éviter le 49-3 et pour essayer de
convaincre
je pense que l'objectif c'est qu'il n'y
ait pas de 49-3 mais pour le cas où les
oppositions durciraient leur position se
poseraient systématiquement dans ce cas
là on peut envisager on doit se garder
la carte de pouvoir avancer par 40 ans
que la droite les républicains en
particulier ont intérêt à voter contre
cette réforme écoutez
j'ai du mal à comprendre les
républicains
en tout cas au Sénat l'amendement déposé
chaque année par sénateur Savary propose
cette solution sans proposer à côté
sinon une convention c'est que propose
aujourd'hui Olivier du socle qui a
beaucoup avancé sur les dossiers
périphériques
sur l'emploi des seniors le pays des
seniors sur les carrières longues les
carrières très longues qui ont été
évoquées cette semaine sur les régimes
spéciaux il ne proposait pas donc là
c'est un package global avec des
avancées importantes y compris la
retraite à 1200 euros bien donc ça les
sénateurs ne le proposent pas donc
proposer à l'Assemblée nationale je
pense qu'il y a des députés républicains
qui se rappellent qu'ils ont voté pour
Valérie Pécresse
dans lesquels la formule était celle
qu'elle retenait la retraite à 65 ans
ils peuvent pas se contredire tous les
jours entre les candidats qui ont été
président de la République
ceux qui sont aujourd'hui au Sénat on va
voir je pense qu'ils vont se diviser par
contre aller voir que les républicains
vont se diviser parce que c'est pas
exactement est-ce que est-ce que vous
êtes je pense que je pense que la
division des républicains va intervenir
aujourd'hui hier soir Éric cioti appelé
au rassemblement je le vois mal opéré à
rassemblement sinon un rassemblement
encore plus à droite qu'il n'est
aujourd'hui ouais on va on va venir sur
la réforme des retraites pour qu'on soit
clair je pense qu'il y a une partie de
républicain Marleix
c'est pas très bien exactement ces
équipes vont aller l'objectif c'est de
convaincre de convaincre les
républicains de vos tests pour éviter
49-3 mais sur quoi est-ce que vous êtes
inflexible sur la retraite à 65 ans
est-ce que le texte de la réforme des
retraites contiendra un report de l'âge
de départ à 65 ans
je crois c'est ce que pendant la
campagne électorale le président a dit
65 madame borne s'est exprimé dans la
presse il y a 15 jours dix jours elle a
dit 65
qui peut m'intervenir donc partons du
fait que ce sera 65 en 2000 je vous
rappelle que c'est en 2031 c'est en 2031
c'est clair donc 2031 et bien et puis on
peut discuter à l'Assemblée il peut y
avoir la ville président de la ville
lui-même on peut bouger sur 64 faire un
mixte avec le nombre de trimestres de
cotisations donc c'est possible aussi ce
que vote le Sénat
64 ans avec un allongement de la durée
de cotisation ça c'est un bon compromis
pour vous c'est possible de ne réviser
là si les députés républicains le vote
sinon on verra voilà et puis même le
gouvernement peut je pense et on part
d'un texte de loi on l'a déjà fait
évolué évoluer au cours de la discussion
sur quoi d'autre sur ces sujets là je
vous rappelle quand même que quand on
chaque jour des gens qui disent il y a
pas besoin il y a pas besoin de faire
dans les formes des retraites j'entends
ceux qui disent aussi qu'il faudrait
encore négocier et négocier ça fait 4
ans Jean-Paul Delevoye a commencé la
discussion les négociations les
syndicats il y a un fait que les
opposants à la retraite à 65 ans ne
veulent pas entendre deux choses la
première en quoi la France serait-elle
c'est îlot miraculeux dans lequel on
pourrait travailler 60 ans ou 62 ans
alors que tous nos voisins travaillent
plus longtemps la deuxième c'est que la
retraite par répartition elle est payée
par les actifs qui payent des retraités
il y a 20 ans il y avait deux actifs
pour un retraité on approche maintenant
de 1,7 actif pour un retraité et en 2030
il y aura 1,5 actifs pour un retraité
donc des facto
si on veut que les gens aient une
retraite descente j'ai dit 1200 euros
pour une carrière pleine
puisse être équilibré il faut réformer
les retraites dans le Journal du
Dimanche hier vous avez sûrement lu
François Bayrou qui dit que les Français
ne sont pas suffisamment informés sur
cette réforme nous n'avons pas
collectivement fait l'effort de
pédagogie nécessaire vous partagez son
constat c'est ce qu'avait déjà dit
François Bayrou lors du dernier l'avant
dernier dîner à l'Élysée le 28 septembre
il pense aujourd'hui que alors que moi
j'ai toujours pensé
que beaucoup de syndicats viendraient la
CGT il est même venu par moment mais que
au bout du compte à partir du moment où
on savait que l'échéance au bout ce
serait dire ce sera 65 ans ou 64 en
fonction des débats et des évolutions
qu'on aura pu obtenir
tu es sûr que ce serait non conclusif on
voit bien ce qu'ils disent aujourd'hui
les syndicats je vois pas ce qu'ils vont
dire autrement de cette semaine ou la
semaine prochaine mais il souhaitait
apparemment aujourd'hui je pense que ce
berger je passe vraiment le rôle des
syndicats réformes amateur qu'il est
qu'il devrait entrer dans la négociation
ne pas être buté comme il est
aujourd'hui et ce que vous trouvez
la question des fois négocier donc à
l'époque le président l'a entendu il a
dit ok on passe pas par un amendement
moi j'étais pour une méthode plus
coercitive je pense qu'on aurait pu
voter la réforme dans le PLFSS on l'a
pas fait pour des raisons que je peux
comprendre par ailleurs celle de ne pas
passer en force celle de laisser un
temps pour les sujets que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure sur lesquels Olivier du
soft a abouti à un accord avec les
syndicats donc c'est bien on a bien fait
de le faire mais maintenant il y a un
moment où il faut dire tout est sur la
table depuis 3 ans
ça revient à une méthode puisque un
budget de la sécurité rectificatif mais
on aura au moins on aura au moins le
gouvernement a au moins d'abord négocier
discuter c'est concerter avec les
syndicats obtenus des avancées à
proposer des avancées importantes sur
les sujets tout à l'heure évoqués
employabilité des seigneurs etc et
carrière longue et très longue ça fait
ce sera dans le texte de loi à côté ce
sera à côté
non non un seul texte tout mettre dans
un budget de sécurité
c'est un projet de loi de finance
mais vous pourrez pas tout mettre quand
même
des mesures l'essentiel dedans et après
il y aura un autre texte pour d'autres
je pense l'essentiel sera dans le texte
donc un projet de loi de finance
rectificatif c'est pas un projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
mais la précision est importante est-ce
que vous pensez parce que là vous dites
il va falloir qu'on parle au répu qu'on
cherche les voies des républicains mais
il y aura pas de difficultés dans votre
majorité à vous entre François Bayrou
qui critique le manque de pédagogie
entre Édouard Philippe qui dit ça va pas
assez loin
le report de l'âge légal de départ vous
pensez que vous aurez toutes les votes
de votre majorité dans ce que j'ai
entendu des partenaires de la majorité
que je rencontrais la semaine dernière
avec d'autres j'ai le sentiment que
chacun ait mis son avis mais qu'au bout
du compte il y aura pas de détection
dans les forces de la majorité non un
mot puisque vous êtes vous avez encore
la fibre socialiste on imagine même si
vous avez quitté le PS quand vous
entendez la gauche quand vous entendez
la gauche défendre la retraite à 60 ans
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
je peux ici m'exprimer et dire après
tout vous êtes en contradiction puisque
moi en 80 j'ai voté la retraite à 60 ans
mais je vous rappelle que il y a 40 ans
les temps n'était pas assez
d'aujourd'hui l'espérance de vie était
différente la nature même des carrières
difficiles étaient différentes moi mon
voisin à l'époque dans mon village qui
était maçon couvreur et qui montait sur
les toits me disait je n'en peux plus de
monter sur les toits comme ça
aujourd'hui la nature le travail n'est
pas la même les déménageurs les couvrant
les gens dans les travaux publics sont
équipés de exosquelettes ils sont
équipés de matériaux aujourd'hui la
pénibilité n'est plus la même
et les soins sont meilleurs aujourd'hui
donc on ne vit pas aujourd'hui comme il
y a 40 ans moi j'ai vu c'était la
génération de la guerre qui était
épuisée par les travaux par la
difficulté y compris dans le
travaux agricoles j'ai connu les travaux
agricoles la pénibilité c'était autre
chose les temps ont changé donc
aujourd'hui dans le contexte que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui et bien je pense
que il faut effectivement revenir à une
retraite à 65 ans oui sauf que je
suppose quand même la question de
l'emploi des seniors qui reste quand
même très impacté par dommage il y a une
il y a peut-être une contradiction sur
ce point là non parce que c'est pas pour
aussi pas pour des raisons de pénibilité
que les gens retraitaient pas pour des
raisons de santé ou pénibilité c'est
parce qu'il y a du taturnover les gens
les entreprises veulent se séparer des
seigneurs parce qu'ils sont en haut de
l'échelle des salaires et qui veulent
déjà d'un côté et je crois qu'il y a des
propositions aujourd'hui importantes on
n'a pas le temps de les décliner
maintenant sur l'employabilité des
seniors qui permettent de répondre en
partie à ce problème est-ce qu'en
passant par un projet de loi de finance
rectificatif François Patriat vous
redoutez une colère sociale au mois de
janvier est-ce que ça va pas accentuer
ce risque de passer par un tel véhicule
législatif
on réforme jamais non mais si à chaque
fois on se dit est-ce que ça va pas être
difficile est-ce qu'il y aura pas des
manifestations est-ce qu'il y aura pas
moi des manifestations j'en ai connu sur
les retraites tous les temps sur le
gouvernement du temps de même à mourir
j'ai connu des manifestations sous
gouvernement Fillon je voulais il y a
toujours eu des manifestations dans ce
domaine aujourd'hui sur légitimes elles
sont victimes vous allez sur vous passer
par un 49 3 c'est pour ça que vous
faites dans le budget rectificatif ils
ont déjà au neuvième 49.3 en 50 jours
vous allez pouvoir tenir longtemps comme
ça
moi je dis que dans cette dans ce
premier trimestre où on disait qu'on
pourrait pas ça passerait pas on n'est
pas de majorité à tous les textes sont
passés tous les terres sont passés y
compris la réforme du travail jusque-là
tout va bien les textes sont passés ils
sont passés bien maintenant on va
rentrer dans un premier semestre on ne
va falloir continuer à réformer sur des
sujets difficiles difficiles il y a
trois ou quatre textes de loi il y a
l'immigration etc qui va venir les
textes de loi difficile et bien je
trouve que c'est là ça c'est la vertu et
le courage du gouvernement non pas de
dire ça va être difficile il y aura des
manifs attendons attendons attendons
toujours attendons attendons toujours et
on s'aperçoit ensuite qu'on a perdu
beaucoup de temps qu'on a reculé les
problèmes que les réformes sont pas
faites et je crois qu'Emmanuel Macron a
bien dit qu'il était élu pour réformer
et là déjà beaucoup réformé
on verra qu'elle sera tech je peux pas
vous dire aujourd'hui on verra on verra
dans les a présenté
je vois que sur les dernières nouvelles
on a aboutit la gauche voté avec nous
c'est ce qu'on a dit c'est ce qu'a dit
le gouvernement au début on va tenter de
trouver des compromis tantôt à gauche
tenter à droite pourquoi faire non pas
pour trouver des compromis à droite ou à
gauche mais pour faire avancer ce pays
c'était l'élection c'était le deuxième
tour ce weekend pour les républicains la
présidence du parti rexioti était élu
face à Bruno Retailleau votre collègue
Center prenons Retailleau ça vous
surprend cette élection directe et puis
est-ce que c'est pas pour vous
l'occasion d'élargir votre base
d'abord le scrutin est plus serré qu'on
ne le pensait c'est 54 46 ou parce que
même 50 3 47 je trouve que pour une
Retailleau qui ne partait pas favori a
su mobiliser les élus je crois que non
pas et c'est la victoire de
direction c'est plutôt une défaite des
élus des grands élus qui sont présentés
au Sénat le soutien de l'archer les
soutiens
Bertrand etc les élus ont été désavoués
on a choisi la voiture qui est l'âge la
voix j'allais dire la plus à droite
peut-être est-il bon de rappeler
aujourd'hui quand même qu'arrive Chiotti
avait dit qu'en Emmanuel Macron Éric
Zemmour et je voudrais Éric Zemmour
ce qui en dit long aujourd'hui sur
peut-être la stratégie en tout cas le
positionnement d'Éric cioti il va
aujourd'hui
la fragmentation va se poursuivre je dis
pas qu'ils vont séparer je crois qu'il
resteront unis et ça veut pas dire
qu'ils vont du tout rejoindre mais je
pense qu'ils peuvent à défaut de nous
rejoindre je pense qu'ils peuvent
rejoindre des positions positions sur
les textes
les amendements sur des lois aujourd'hui
qui nous permettront d'avoir la majorité
mais ça veut pas dire demain que que le
parti va se raconter tout de suite vous
n'y croyez continuez à division la
division je pense que au Sénat par
exemple la majorité des sénateurs
suivront leur président une petite
partie va aller sur érections
une partie aujourd'hui est plus proche
de nous mais que dans un premier temps
il y aura peut-être quelques défections
mais je ne vois pas le groupe bouger
les sénateurs a tendance centriste vous
les appelez à rejoindre la majorité
présidentielle aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
je leur demande pas de rejoindre le
groupe au Sénat dans ce petit jeu là on
n'avance pas on va toujours dans un
groupe où on garde son indépendance où
on peut voter un peu ce qu'on veut ou on
n'est pas identifié comme tel donc moi
je parle avec les sénateurs avec les
sénateurs républicains je parle avec les
éditeurs centristes ils disent
qu'aujourd'hui ils nous rejoignent sur
des positions mais que la discipline
fait que sur cette attaque ils ne
viennent pas on la semaine dernière
encore notamment sur la délégation au
droit de l'enfant où j'ai trouvé que la
position est de républicain était dur et
même y compris des centrist de ne pas
reconnaître une délégation au droit de
l'enfant quand on connaît aujourd'hui
drame qui se passe dans notre pays on a
vu quand même que là son corps soudés
donc je pense que la fragmentation va se
poursuivre je crois que ce mouvement
républicains vont encore on revient au
RPR
très à droite on vient au RPR
aujourd'hui et vous pensez que que le LR
peuvent se tourner vers l'extrême droite
non je pense que je pense qu'aujourd'hui
symbiose entre l'extrême droite et la
droite va se poursuivre
il y a des gens qui aujourd'hui Marine
Le Pen fait tout pour ça d'ailleurs
pareil et Eric Zemmour avec le
rassemblement des droites donc je crois
que ça veut dire
il va essayer de dire je vais redonner
je ne vois pas cette stratégie est une
stratégie de rassemblement et aboutir
demain à un renfort chez le républicain
mais ça va aboutir à quoi parce que
Édouard Philippe on s'en souvient au
début du premier quinquennat d'Emmanuel
Macron il disait la poutre travaille
encore est-ce que la poutre travaille en
fait j'ai pas voulu reprendre le mot
mais j'y pensais fortement la poutre
travaille encore aujourd'hui en faveur
de cette élection chez les républicains
je ne sais pas mais l'extrême droite le
côté sécurité ultra sécurité et le
populisme oui
donc c'est Marine Le Pen la gagnante
c'est Eric Zemmour le gagnant je pense
que dans cette affaire ils doivent se
frotter les mains aujourd'hui Stéphane
c'est journée le patron de votre partie
dit ce matin dans le Parisien que le
l'élection d'Erik sotti marque un coup
d'arrêt à un éventuel accord d'appareils
entre vous et les républicains vous êtes
d'accord avec ça c'était leur position
c'est clair je mets même
sur un taillot Bruno retaillod n'était
pas d'accord du tout
je pense que on a cherché depuis le
début c'était législature à ce qui est
un accord de gouvernement sur des textes
on l'a pas obtenu
l'élection de risotti on marque le glas
définitif en l'occurrence sur votre
majorité psychiatre des sénatoriales que
vous préparez François Patriot avec
attention est-ce que il vous souhaitez
un groupe horizon au Sénat est-ce qu'il
y aura des candidats horizon
nous sommes trois parties dans la
majorité de renaissance
le modem est horizon
nous discutons aujourd'hui pour savoir
comment lors des sénatoriales on aura
des candidats les mieux placés et mieux
placés pour pouvoir gagner des sénateurs
ce n'est pas facile compte tenu du
résultat des municipales que vous
connaissez
je ne sais moi je aujourd'hui il y a un
groupe présidé par des gens qui sont à
horizons le groupe
aujourd'hui de monsieur malurede qui
aujourd'hui a 10 ou 11 membres je pense
qu'à l'issue des élections j'espère
qu'on progresse à tous
donc ce groupe il existe sans avoir ce
nom des facto aujourd'hui comme tel
moi ce que je souhaite c'est qui est le
maximum de sénateurs qui votent avec
nous les lois alors bien sûr s'ils sont
RDP le groupe sera plus important que le
groupe Renaissance dans le nouveau Sénat
nous sommes 24 le groupe horizon il est
10 je pense pas que nous puissions
dans le mouvement de l'horizon vous
dites aujourd'hui mais je ne vois pas se
traduire ça en tant que tel je vous
sénatorial comme tel je pense que vous
savez la physionomie du Sénat compte
tenu du corps électoral évoluera peu
elle évoluera peu donc il y aura
quelques mouvements j'espère que nous
progresserons
majoritaire je pense que la droite
restera majoritaire au Sénat une
dernière question Philippe est très
populaire dans l'opinion il a été
premier ministre de d'Emmanuel Macron
quel rôle doit-il jouer selon vous là
dans les mois les années qui viennent
dans cette majorité mais je crois que
d'abord j'ai pas addicté le rôle de
Édouard Philippe mais par ailleurs je
crois qu'il doit il a dit qu'il ferait
preuve de loyauté il l'a fait pour
l'élection présidentielle depuis je n'ai
pas entendu marquer vraiment sa
différence sauf une déclaration sur les
retraites que j'ai vu que je n'ai pas
entendu collaborer la semaine dernière
par ailleurs je crois que c'est
horizon c'est un parti d'élus c'est pas
un parti de masse c'est un parti début
qui aujourd'hui plus il y a des lieux
y compris dans les dans les étages plus
communaux régionaux départementaux qui
soutiennent la majorité mais ce sera
j'espère que
je vais dire qu'on va gagner des voies
dans ces secteurs là mais les élections
futures régionales cantonales elles sont
pour beaucoup plus loin je dois donc je
pense que Edward Philippe il peut avoir
il peut avoir une voix il peut avoir une
voix celle de celle de la réforme celle
de pousser à la réforme c'est ce que
j'attends de lui aujourd'hui de dire
voilà continuons les réformes de ce pays
il va falloir faire des réformes
institutionnelles on leur fait réforme
de l'État il faudra faire encore rouge
dans les quatre ans qui viennent et
j'attends ce rôle important sur ces
sujets merci François patriar merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité et de
nous annoncer donc cette réforme d'un
traite passera par un projet de loi de
finance rectificatif merci beaucoup
François Patriat merci Fabrice on passe
au club des territoires